(whooshing noise)
(ball bounce)
- [Evan] The extraordinary
way to one million dollars.
If I'm able to live an extraordinary life,
If I'm able to do extraordinary things,
there's a gift in that.
If I'm an extraordinary father,
that's a gift from my kids.
If I'm able to run an
extraordinary business,
with extraordinary people,
that's a culture that I'm
able to give my staff.
Mark Drager, CEO of Phanta Media.
Mark Drager didn't want to be ordinary.
After being an entrepreneur for years
he found himself feeling
more and more like
he wasn't making a
significant contribution
to his video production company
Phanta Media.
He had grown his business, hired people
to do most of the tasks
that he used to do.
But he wanted to do something meaningful.
Mark felt lost.
After about six months of
thinking about his role
he realized that his motivation
didn't come from money.
It never did.
The prospect of making more money
wouldn't push him to work harder.
His motivation comes from
recognition by others.
He wants to stand out.
He realized that he had a
deep fear of being ordinary
in all areas of his life.
Mark wanted to be extraordinary.
He wanted to be an extraordinary husband.
An extraordinary father to his four kids.
And extraordinary man of faith.
An extraordinary member of his community.
And, an extraordinary entrepreneur.
When he was doing something extraordinary
it made him happy.
That was the connective tissue for him.
It was missing in his business
which made him feel lost.
And for him to be happy and successful
he knew he had to build his business
around being extraordinary.
So he changed his company's mission
to creating extraordinary video
and aligned his entire business around it.
He hires extraordinary staff members.
He works on extraordinary projects.
He creates extraordinary
results for his clients.
And his team holds him
accountable, as well
to make sure everyone is
given an extraordinary effort.
Focusing on being
extraordinary helped Mark
pass his million dollar revenue goal
and now he's going for more.
Finding his one word wasn't
something that came easily
but by digging deeper into who he was
it became clear to him
and it can become clear to you, as well.
(whooshing noise)
(ball bounce)